I've been reading the book How to Starve Your Cancer and I've only got halfway through.
Do you agree with what she's success, what she's been supporting, and the book in terms
of all the drugs and protocols she suggests is Jade McClellan's book.
With my recent rise in two markers, I'm getting nervous all over and continue to look for answers.
So yes, a lot of her things, we have some of our members that are using some of the protocols
that all of them, and some of them make sense.
So you can go through Google Care on College, that's who all of our other members are going
through to use those protocols, and you can pick and choose what you want to do.
Some of them seem to be four different cancers seem to make a little bit less sense, but
some of them can make a lot of sense, and that can be another approach that you can take
and if there's no change in what we would do, you would do it.
The nutritional approach, you could just add those to your approach as well.